two weeks ago United Airlines got hit
with a slew of horrible headlines after
airline security forcibly removed a
passenger from a flight after he was
seated and refused to obey airline
orders to vacate the plane the man dr.
david dowell alleges that security broke
his nose and knocked out his teeth among
other injuries the story led to a bevy
of narratives about suppose an anti
Asian discrimination on Airlines as well
as general anger at the airline industry
on Monday a lawyer named Tom de metrio
announced on NBC's Today that a female
passenger on American Airlines had
contacted him about suing the airline
what happened a video shows the woman
crying and carrying her baby as well as
another passenger talking to a flight
attendant the woman claims a flight
attendant hit her with a stroller while
taking it away from her nearly hitting
her kid to American Airlines seeing what
had happened United immediately took
action to suspend the flight attendant
in question and apologized for quote the
pain we have caused this passenger and
her family and to any other customers
affected by the incident according to a
reddit commenter who says he saw the
incident quote the argentinian lady and
her two children were in the mid-to back
of the plane she was somehow able to get
her stroller on board and back to near
her seat since I was near the front I
cannot know what happened if she tried
to put the stroller in the overhead bin
or what the flight attendant told her
she could not have the stroller on the
plane and he needs to take it she
refused to let him take it and was to
the near point of shouting the flight
attendant shouted up for security very
soon on escalating situation more the
flight attendant and the woman started
making their way to the front of the
plane I forgot who had the stroller at
this point she had her two kids she
shouted something about being an
argentinian woman in yada-yada it was at
this point where things escalated a bit
more the flight attendant an argentinian
woman were at the front of the plane in
the crew area next to the front door of
the plane she was hanging on to the
stroller refusing to let go the flight
attendant was trying to remove it from
the plane both were here at fault in my
opinion the flight attendant stone was
overly aggressive the woman was refusing
to let it go and made an aggressive move
grabbing the flight attendant which he
should not have done this angered him he
responded by jerking the stroller harder
and knocking the argentinian woman in
the head and nearly missing her kids the
flight attendant should not have been so
aggressive and should have been aware of
the kids unquote so here's the problem
what we now have is an attempt to target
one of the most unpopular industries in
the country everyone hates the airlines
the same way most Americans hate their
insurance company sure we need the
airlines but we despised them because
they control how we fly they charge us
too much they jack us around they force
us to pay for check baggage and the like
we have to deal with pissy flight
attendant an idiot TSH
and airlines that don't seem to care
very much about canceling or delaying
our flights and so now individual CL
ripe target here is the truth
David Dow should have gotten off the
plane they had the legal right to remove
him from the plane should they have
changed the process for encouraging
people to leave of course but is micro
rightly sad quote I don't want to fly
across the country in a steel tube
filled with people who get to decide
which rules they will follow in which
they will ignore I've been on too many
flights with too many angry people to
worry about the specific circumstances
of their outrage or the details of why
they took it upon themselves to ignore
the recommend a plane is not a democracy
the main cabin is no place to organize a
sit-in the main cabin is a place to
follow orders unquote the same holds
true for this woman on the American
Airlines flight I have two kids under
the age of four we always travel with a
double stroller
we have never attempted to put it on the
plane and if we did so and were asked to
check the stroller instead we would obey
the command apparently this woman didn't
then allegedly got rowdy before being
clocked with the stroller in stupid
fashion by flight attendant how is this
the sort of behavior we'd like to
promulgate as a society we're now
incentivizing every person on every
plane to argue with every annoyance and
then sue based on the reaction from the
airline those costs will then be passed
on to other consumers enough we've had
politics dominated by hatred for
particular industries for years now
we've already destroyed the health
insurance industry because we hate it
but we need it now will target the
airlines here's an idea if you don't
like how an airline acts choose a
different airline otherwise we'll ruin
all of the airlines in a fit of pique
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
we have tons to get to today we're gonna
be having on a guest you think the
cultural appropriation is completely
horrible in just a little while plus I
want to go through what Trump promised
during his first 100 days and what he's
actually done we're gonna go through
this in purely factual fashion see what
he is fulfilled and what he has not
fulfilled but first I want to say thank
you to our sponsors over a texture calm
so if you are addicted to information as
I am if you love reading as I do you
need to go to texture comm slash men and
download their app what do they do well
they make it possible for you to access
200 plus magazines full of in-depth
interviews and stories all in the
texture app right there on your tablet
or your phone and you can do all of that
for a really low price every single
month it's a $9.99 a month you get over
200 magazines and these are top level
magazines we're not talking about
magazines you've never heard of we're
talking about things like popular
science and and InStyle and Harper's
Bazaar and GQ and and Sports Illustrated
all these all these magazines that you
probably subscribe to on your own and
looking a list of them and it's a huge
list all of these magazines are
available to you for one low monthly
price and you have access to all of them
it was selected as one of Apple's top
2016 iPad apps as well it should have
been you can start your free trial right
now and download the texture app my wife
uses it for Reader's Digest I use it for
Sports Illustrated texture calm slash
reading at 14 days free trial to check
it out it's entirely digital of course
it is only $9.99 a month less than the
cost of many of these just on their own
like if you're just a to get a
subscription one of these magazines
would probably cost more than $9.99 a
month for some of these magazines so get
that you get 200 magazines plus so it's
just fantastic stuff time the Atlantic
Newsweek doesn't matter nice thing is it
doesn't matter if you don't like the
whole magazine you're subscribed to so
many of them you can pick and choose
what it is that you want to read if you
love reading if you love information if
you're an information junkie as I am
then texture comm slash Ben is the place
to be okay so before we launch into the
news of the day I want to talk about a
piece of news that's not of the dates of
102 years ago I want to pay tribute to
the Armenian Genocide see Armenian
genocide began 102 years ago April 24th
1915 people don't know that much about
the Armenian Genocide because it hasn't
had as much publicity as the Holocaust
because it wasn't as mechanized at the
Holocaust but up to 1.5 million
Armenians were murdered by the Turkish
Islamist regime now called The Young
Turks they took the place of the Ottoman
Empire they're supposed to be reason
and nationalists and instead it turned
out that they were Islamic extremists
and they decided on the murder of
literally hundreds of thousands of men
women and children who are Armenian in
Turkey and it was I mean the stories
that the pictures are just horrific I
mean you're talking about mass killings
you're talking about mass starvation
force death marches there's famous news
coverage of them putting boats filled
with women and children offshore into
the sea and then just deliberately
sinking them to kill everybody aboard a
horrific the the excuse that was used by
the regime at the time is that these
terrible Armenians who are Christian
we're going to be allied against the
central powers in World War one and they
wanted to stop that still today the
current Islamist dictator of Turkey
refuses to acknowledge the Armenian
Genocide in 2010 Berlin who is that
dictator he openly warned he could throw
a hundred thousand Armenian immigrants
out of Turkey if they kept talking about
the Armenian Genocide because they were
undermining the legitimacy of Turkish
rule there's one guy who took the
Armenian Genocide particularly seriously
that person was Adolf Hitler in 1939
when he was dictator of Germany
obviously he told Nazi officers right
before they were about to invade Poland
quote kill without mercy he said who
after all speaks today of the
annihilation of the Armenians the
Germans were obviously well aware of the
annihilation of the Armenians because
they were allied with the the Turkish
Empire with the Ottoman Empire in World
War one rabbi shmuel boat has pointed
out that Hitler's conference learned
from turkeys genocidal playbook his lead
political adviser Hitler's was going to
max orwen bunch of Nerissa
who's a young German consular officer in
Turkey and he had seen all of this
happen the Germans were well aware of
what had happened during the Armenian
Genocide again the bottom line is that
most genocides are thrown off as some
sort of political just a political tool
and the world tends to ignore it most of
the world ignored the Armenian Genocide
most of the world still ignore the
Armenian Genocide I thought it would be
you know not only worthwhile to pay
tribute to it it's a reminder that when
we watch genocides happening across the
world against Christians particularly in
the Middle East today the legacy of this
is not over when you ignore Islamic
extremism genocide becomes far easier
whether it's genocide against the sdds
in Iraq or whether it's genocide against
Christians in Syria a bottom line is
that Christians are so under attack in
the Middle East by the same people who
are participating in this century ago
okay so I now want to talk about Trump's
first 100 days so truck made a lot of
promises about what he's going to do his
first hundred days he had an entire
program that he suggested was going to
be his agreement with America it was a
100-day plan to restore prosperity to
our economy security to our communities
and honesty to our government you can
see an image of what he had tweeted out
and put out this contract with the
American voter now supposed to be like
Newt Gingrich's Contract with America
and it had I think 28 separate promises
and we'll go through those promises and
see what he's fulfilled now let's be
real about this 100-day standard is
always sort of silly it was established
by historians in the aftermath of FDR
using his first hundred days to cram
through whatever he wanted so when Trump
says that it's silly he's right but it
was from himself who decided to hold by
this and make all these big promises
because the big promise underlying
everything Trump did in the election
cycle was that Donald Trump was going to
change the way government worked he was
going to come in cut the Gordian not
everything was going to be quick and
easy and fast and that's not the way
that government works yeah Chuck Todd
asked Reince Priebus about this because
Trump had been asked about the hundred
days thing and Trump had said well I
don't know who decided on that somebody
decided on this meaning somebody decided
on this program so this Bob the intern
apparently who came up with this
contract with the American voter but
here's Chuck Todd querying Reince
Priebus over it and Reince Priebus
trying to run from it all of them were
supposed to be legislative action that
was announced not necessarily the
expectation anybody passed but only one
of those legislative priorities has even
come close to health care why does he
say it's a ridiculous standard and yet
promised all this action and before day
100 all right and in previous doesn't
have a great answer for that Jonathan
Karl over at ABC News is of course
something on the 100 day standard to
stated Trump has fallen short by the
standards that he set for himself during
the campaign there is no question that
he has fallen dramatically short in the
first 100 days just take a look at this
back in October he offered what he
called a contract with the American
voter this is ten specific promises ten
pieces of legislation that he promised
to introduce and quote fight for their
passage within the first 100 days of my
administration
well George only one of those has even
been introduced okay and that's going to
appeal it is not fully fair so if you
look at from 100-day Prime
mrs. they're focusing on the legislative
portion of it right there's the 100-day
promises again so this is the first page
the second page is the one where he
hasn't done so well right so the second
page has all of these legislative
priorities he pledges that he's going to
introduce these acts middle-class tax
relief and simplification know and the
offshoring Act which was supposed to be
a tariff act no American energy and
infrastructure act no school choice and
education Opportunity Act no repeal and
replace Obamacare Act he tried it failed
affordable child care and elder care Act
no any legal immigration act no
restoring Community Safety Act no
restoring national security act no clean
up corruption in Washington AG no so
that that page that's right those are
all his supposed legislative priorities
and this highlights the difference I'll
show you in a second this highlights the
difference between where Trump has been
effective and where he has not been
effective he has not been effective at
changing how government works and this
is why he is not Reagan so Reagan in his
first hundred days pursued some
executive actions but Reagan's big
contribution was to spend his first
hundred days on the bully pulpit ripping
Democrats down remember at a Democratic
majority in the house ripping Democrats
down for their failure to pass some sort
of tax reform and he was successful in
shifting the debate Trump has not really
shifted the debate on anything which is
why he's been wildly unsuccessful on the
legislative front
even though unlike Reagan he actually
has a Republican Congress and a
Republican Senate here's where he has
fulfilled his promises that first page
let's show that first page again okay so
the first page has a bunch of promises
here so he pledged he was going to clean
up government so he said he's going to
propose a constitutional amendment to
impose term limits on all members of
Congress no he didn't do that a hiring
freeze on federal employees yes he
lifted it later but yes third a
requirement that for every new federal
regulation to existing regulations would
be eliminated yes he fulfilled that a
five-year ban on White House and
congressional officials becoming
lobbyists after they leave government
service yes you fulfilled that a
lifetime ban on White House officials
lobbying on behalf of a foreign
government
yes but sort of undercut by the fact
that Mike Flynn who is his national
security adviser is now registered as a
foreign agent sick a complete ban on
foreign lobbyists raising money for
American elections no he hasn't done
that yet so that first section here you
can see is here on the left side of your
screen there are six promises that he
made and he kept four of them okay not
bad I'm protecting American workers he
now said he was going to renegotiate
NAFTA or withdraw from the deal he has
announced that he would
he said he was going to announce
withdrawal from TPP yes he said that he
was going to direct his secretary of the
Treasury to label China a currency
manipulator no and not only now he said
he was never going to do that now
because they're not manipulating the
currency he said he's going to direct
the Secretary of Commerce and US Trade
Representative to identify foreign
trading abuses yes he's going to lift
restrictions on generation of shale oil
natural gas and clean coal yes
lifts the Keystone pipeline ban yes and
cancel billions to the UN climate change
programs yes so in this section he has
kept one two three there were there
seven promises here and he has kept six
of them so quite good right and then
there are his promises on the
Constitution he said he was going to
cancel every unconstitutional executive
action memo and order issued by Obama no
particularly does not sure with regard
to the firt action on childhood arrivals
daca second he said he was going to
select a replacement for Scalia yes in
spades with with judge Gorsuch third
cancel all federal funding to sanctuary
cities he has said he's going to do this
and he's made that threat fourth begin
removing two million criminal illegal
immigrants guess he's pursuing that and
suspending immigration from terror prone
countries he's tried to do that but
obviously he's failed in that because of
the the courts attempting to block that
so what if he's on there so there were
five promises there and he has capped
four of them essentially so in other
words everything that he said he could
do that was kind of the smaller things
through executive action he's done all
of that when it comes to legislative
efforts he has not done that now here is
the problem with that the problem with
that is that the big things the
presidents do are all legislative try to
recall that the president really does
big things in a couple of ways one is he
shifts the tone and tenor of the
political debate so Barack Obama shifted
the entire tone and tenor of the
American political debate on to race on
to on to gender on to polarization of
the American system and he did that very
successfully also his big
accomplishments were legislative except
for daca which oh but which Trump is not
moving off of so his big legislative
accomplishment of course is Obama care
he also came up with sequestration which
cut the military dramatically all of his
big accomplishments were legislative
this is true for every president
executive orders do not do that much
okay executive orders generally if
they're properly used cannot do that
much because the president doesn't have
all that much power so while everybody
is saying that Trump kept a lot of these
promises that's true
good for him but when it comes to what
the president actually
his role of leadership Trump is a mixed
bag he has not done anything on the
legislative side he's supposed to roll
out his tax plan this week we'll see how
that goes hopefully it goes better than
repeal in her place he had said he was
going to do repeal and replace this week
again doesn't look like that's going to
happen that probably gets kicked down
the road maybe Trump pulls out of this
tailspin but he has not used the bully
pulpit in order to promulgate his agenda
and you can see that so for example
Donald Trump is still maintaining that
Mexico is going to pay for the wall
there's no evidence that Mexico is going
to pay for this wall right he said
eventually but at a later date so we can
get started early Mexico will be paying
in some form for the badly needed border
wall so bottom line he had just three
times in one tweet about one of his key
campaign promises eventually but at a
later date in some form right it's good
a lot of hedging about a key campaign
promise his homeland security treaty on
Trump said it's going to be so easy to
stop terrorism it's not easy to stop
terrorism never should have made that
promise
Harris's homeland security chief is
General John Kelly talking about how no
we really don't know what we can do here
there's so many aspects of this
terrorist thing obviously you get the
homegrown terrorists I don't know how to
stop that I don't know how to detect
that okay so again promise the Trump
made that he's not gonna be able to
fulfill because there's no way to
fulfill that promise
Jeff Sessions the the Attorney General
was asked about supporting dreamers
another big Obama another big Trump
initiative to say deal we're going to
revoke daca and deport the dreamers no
not so much
the President did say as I said this
week to The Associated Press that the
dreamers should rest easy he's not going
after the dreamers that's his policy he
said is it the policy of the Justice
Department that the Homeland Security
has primary jurisdiction they're their
first and strongest priority no doubt
about it is the criminal element that we
have in our country that have come here
illegally so they're focusing primarily
on that and there's no doubt the
president has sympathy for young people
who were brought here at early ages so
they can rest easy well I will see I
believe that everyone that enters the
country unlawfully is subject to being
deported however we've got we don't have
the ability to around us every timeline
is mixed messages from Jeff Sessions
again this is stuff that should be
solved on the legislative level and
has not done what he needs to do on the
legislative level yet so on the
executive level I think Trump's done a
lot of the right things on in his first
hundred days but people who are
declaring him a wild success after 100
days are not right and people who are
declaring him a wild failure after 100
days are not right bottom line is I
don't think that he shifted the debate
in the same way that Reagan did he looks
more like Clinton in his in his first
term right so the first hundred days in
Clinton was basically a bunch of
mishmash and even the New York Times
said that it was a bunch of mishmash at
the time and then later he ended up
swiveling to the right he could very
well see Trump do the same thing
swiveling to the left trying to get
Democrats to sign onto his legislative
agenda I want to stop here and say thank
you to our friends over at Zeile comm so
if you are interested in getting a
massage and they give great massages
he'll calm is the best place to do this
fantastic service the way this works is
you go to zeal you download their app
you go to zeal comm they check your idea
to make sure you're not a creeper and
then you can get a massage at your house
on demand and they have a licensed
masseuse who will come to your house
bring all the materials they bring the
table they bring the music they bring
the oils the whole thing it is really a
luxury experience I've done it my wife
has done it my father has done it my
sister has done it my mother-in-law has
done it this is one of the services that
we use a lot in the Shapiro clan zeal
comm and if use promo code been yet $25
off your first massage and 20% off all
massages plus a free massage table and
sheet set if you sign up for zeals
massage membership so you sign up for a
membership card you actually get one of
those you can just have it at your house
which is awesome $25 off your first
massage 20% off all massages yield calm
promo code been one of the things I've
always said is that in life you know
it's good to be rich but it's better to
feel rich and this is one of those
things where it just feels like a luxury
even though it's really affordable it's
less expensive than if you had to go
wait for an appointment at your local
spa and it's it's just it's a tremendous
service I can't recommend it highly
enough it you're worried about your kids
you're stressed out you need a massage
he'll calm is the place to go use that
promo code Ben again it's it got me and
good with my mother-in-law like I had
one that I was getting for myself and
she was at the house I was like you take
it and ever since our relationship has
been spectacular so if you want if you
want a great relationship with your
mother-in-law or any other member of
your family then use this and get a gift
for somebody he'll calm promo code Ben
25 bucks off your first massage 20% off
of all massages and that free massage
table and sheet set if you get their
massage membership
okay so the bottom line here is that the
thing that Trump says that he is good at
the thing Trump thinks he is good at
which is the PR is the thing that he's
actually worst at what he is best at is
implementing a bunch of things that are
inherent in the power of the presidency
he needs to get good at pushing his
agenda if he had discipline he could be
I still hope he will be but I think he
is drawn by the bright light in and that
is not a great thing so you know Donald
Trump said that you know Sean Spicer who
has not been particularly great press
secretary he should stick around why
because he's getting ratings he actually
said this he said that the Spicer's not
going anywhere because he gets ratings
the purpose of the presidency is not to
gain attention you're going to have
attention if your presidents of the
United States the purpose is to get
things done mr. president it's time to
get things done okay well as we continue
here on the bench Shapiro show we're
going to be talking with so you're going
to want to subscribe so it's going to be
fun we're going to talk with a person
who is a professor of one anthropology
at the University of California Irvine
School of Law and she has an AV from
Harvard and and she suggests that
cultural appropriation is the worst
thing in the world we're going to talk
about cultural appropriation and why I
think the entire terminology is really
stupid in just a second but you're going
to have to go over to daily wire.com
right now and subscribe for that $8 a
month gets you the subscription over at
daily wire.com if you subscribe annually
then you get a free copy of the arroyo
fictional film set on the southern
border terrific movie by our very own
Jeremy boring about ranchers trying to
protect our property from drug cartels
trying to use that property as a
thoroughfare for drugs and human
trafficking and you go check it out over
at daily wired.com right now become an
annual subscriber or if you just want to
listen later at iTunes or SoundCloud
then go over to iTunes and hit that
subscribe button we always appreciate it
and make sure that you leave a review we
always appreciate that as well I'm also
going to leave a bad review in which
case you know go screw yourself but if
you're actually gonna leave a good
review then leave a good review
appreciate it already so we'll continue
in just a second this is the largest
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
you